[Music]
my name's Armas Tonia and the author of
fully automated luxury communism I'm the
co-founder of our media I think I'm a
broadcaster and activist and I hope I'm
also a writer had a great day here at
how the light gets in laughs and thank
you for joining us first of all what is
your vision of fully automated luxury
communism it's less a vision it's more
an assessment of what's going on right
now and what I call the great disorder
which is a set of crises which would
define the 21st century
it's how alongside that great disorder
we're seeing the emergence of a new set
of parameters within which we should
understand a potential socialism again
for the 21st century appropriate
politics not just the Christ also for
the possibilities and the third part of
the book is about a road map how do we
break with neoliberalism how do we get
to something new and so I suppose an
answering your question that third part
is the most relevant and so in the book
I talk about really three big things to
break with neoliberalism and to embrace
a project of radical social democracy is
the kind of bridge to fully automated
luxury communism and that's about
universal basic services withdrawing
health housing education transport
information from commodity circulation
make them free the point of use made
them universally available
it's about socializing finance so we use
finance for socially useful projects
rather than casino capitalism
shareholder buybacks debt leveraged
buyouts leather glazes of Manchester
United or a Cadbury buy craft and
finally it's about the present model so
it's about how do we use the leverage of
the states through procurement to
radically transform local economies
mitigate region and the quality mitigate
income inequality and really rebalance
Britain's economy because right now in
terms of this country in particular we
have one of the most centralized
economies you can imagine and people
talk about income inequality which is a
massive problem but in London things
look pretty good you go to Mansfield you
go to Crewe you got a derby these people
are really quite unquote left behind
that's a cliche but it's also very very
very true and so that radical form of
social democracy takes on regional and
quality takes on income inequality and
likewise
a it creates the first steps to moving
towards what I think is a is a new mode
of production it's like very very very
different to capitalism as we know it
paint me a picture of what fully
automated logic on ISM will look like so
I'm gonna disappoint you because I'm not
offering a blueprint in the book for
what it looks like Karl Marx said I'm
not here to write recipes the cook shops
of the future like I said it's a
diagnosis of where we are and it's about
a set of premises for where we could go
however what would be the kinds of
things that wouldn't exist in this
society because I'm claiming it society
beyond scarcity in many areas it's a
society beyond work it's a society
beyond any distinction with manual and
cognitive work between leisure and labor
and what's interesting is actually if
the last couple of hundred years people
have lived under those conditions they
called the aristocracy and so when
people say to me oh well you know people
always fool out they'll always have
arguments they'll always be having a yes
I've read Jane Austen I've read
Dostoyevsky all those things happen
aristocrats fall in and out of love
Dangerous Liaisons bollock loss very
passionate love affairs but I'd far
rather cry myself to sleep over losing a
game of cars or a passionate love affair
then being unable to feed my child or
have a pension as I get old so those the
kinds of problems I think we should be
thinking about in a world beyond work
and scarcity so let's go a little bit
into the analysis that you make in your
book you argue that the economic
structures and material conditions of
human society have been transformed in
the past by to disruption the
domestication of animals and crops and
the Industrial Revolution and that a
third disruption is in coming that will
make the Lords many luxury come as
impossible
what is its third disruption yeah so the
third disruption is just a seismic as
this first and second this what can you
talk about the first disruption is
twelve thousand years ago the
agriculture revolution what we need to
understand is that human beings two
hundred thousand years ago with the
exact same physiology as you and eyes
same brains same frontal cortex same
executive function we're walking around
two hundred thousand years ago that's
most of human history if something
changes twelve thousand years ago we
master agriculture we domesticate
animals we work that we we work out that
we can breed in and out certain features
that changes everything
because on that innovation we then get
cities
culture hierarchy increasingly complex
forms of society a huge huge shift so
when people talk about human nature
human nature for pretty much all of our
existence was something dramatically
different to what happens after though
that thing 12,000 years ago now that's
the first disruption the second one the
industrial evolution turned 50 years ago
you had the steam engine combined with
fossil fuels at this point early 1800s
generally no literacy you have obviously
terrible gender rights but you have
pretty much everybody living in
destitution poor health life expectancy
is around 30 globally today got 7.5
billion people have very high rates of
literacy we've got elevated levels of
gender rights reproductive rights and
it's in arguable that the world is a
much much better place to live the
world's much smaller place so Phileas
Fogg talks about traveling around the
world in 80 days
25 years before that book was written
the same journey takes about a year so
if you want a snapshot of how much
change and how quickly and how that
fostered a sense of global community I
think that's a very powerful way of
looking at it now the third disruption
is I think just as big as the first one
the first destruction is pretty bigger
than the second one if we're being real
and the implications are ad what general
artificial intelligence does to a labor
market is so powerful that I think it
posed an existential challenge to
capitalism because if a machine can do
anything that human can for a cheaper
cost that does a few things in the short
term it depresses the price that a
worker can demand that they're paid for
their work but in there in the longer
term it means that pretty much every job
can essentially be eliminated now under
conditions of capitalism those jobs
won't necessarily be eliminated right
because already we could automate vast
ways the economy we don't because the
workers themselves are so cheap there's
a political tension there but what
general artificial intelligence machine
learning being rolled out the whole
economy well that could do in terms of
the core assumptions of capitalism and
commendably powerful and so I think the
fall teams were kind of status quo logic
captors will always create jobs it'll
always allow us to find new markets new
products etc I don't agree with that I
think that combined with the climate
crisis demographic aging means we have
to think very very deeply about the kind
of society we want to build on the
dividend of these kinds of technologies
and I think that necessitates a break
with capitalism
provisions and structures do we need to
put in place to make sure that
blue-collar workers aren't made
redundant by automation it's a really
powerful question right now you've got
the labor parts to come out green you
deal and there's real ambivalence from
blue-collar workers the labor movement
because their last time they engage with
energy transition was coal right we've
got rid of coal co2 emissions fell lots
of people lost jobs and livelihoods
whole communities were destroyed as a
result now I think what happens with
mining in Britain in the 80s and parts
of North East Midlands you're looking at
lots of the economy being subject to
very similar tendencies and so the only
way that workers can navigate this and
win from this is by having a political
disposition towards technological change
which doesn't deny it's happening which
as this is happening
it does make possible a different kind
of society or reduce working week
universal basic services and if they
don't opt for that politics they're in
deep trouble just as the coal miners
have to say yes we should stop using
coal but instead let's be upskilled
let's use this and know-how and these
people in other areas and renewables
that's what could have been pursued
obvious it wasn't a matter of Thatcher
but clearly the answer was never to say
let's keep on burning coal the answer
can't be for blue-collar workers today
let's keep on doing the jobs we want to
do because for capitalism it's about
competition they'll always go where
things are cheapest and something which
is done by a human is not to be able to
compete on price with something done by
a machine
whether it's steel production whether
it's driving whether it's garment
manufacture so this book I think is
incredibly salient to blue-collar
workers as much as anybody else you have
this belief that fully automated logic
to communism will in your own words
provide infinity does that overlook a
need to both the scale industry to
combat climate change and to
redistribute wealth to the global South
laws beings oh great question if you go
to assaulting in Sussex Salida it's
bought in the 1930s it's gorgeous
you gotta Penzance very very similar
lighter outdoor swimming pool gorgeous
we've built that for working-class
people
80 years ago and yet in 2019 is
apparently utopian demand you know why
because we've been subject to a 48
counter-revolution from Thatcherism from
neoliberalism
saying that this as utopian 1952
the Golden Lane estate was built next to
Barbican had a nursery had a swimming
pool had tennis courts this was built
for working-class Londoners 67 years ago
and if you would suggest that today in
central London that kind of housing for
ordinary people impossible how can you
do that with all these crises we're
facing know we've had a
counter-revolution which is really none
descents a possibility and I would say
if you think we can't have infinity
pools for all it's an ideological claim
because well the capitalist class have
been so powerful at is veiling hiding
from us the ingenuity the infinite
ingenuity or most of our own species and
that's something I want people to get
back in touch with with this book you
know we can now edit our own genome we
can automate I think over the next 40 or
50 years most jobs we can create beef
burgers without killing animals this is
huge this is not science fiction it's
already here the question is whose
interest as it serve what about climbing
trees though well so for instance say
your agriculture is a great example talk
about water as well we're not in trouble
with regards to water use because swim
pools I think I think over 50 percent of
water fresh water used by human beings
is for meat right so if you look even
most crops we grow our to feed animals
that we then eat and actually if you
look at me as a series of chemical
reactions a very inefficient way to eat
right because everything you see all
this greenery here almost every
life-form on earth there's some at the
bottom of the ocean which aren't but
almost everything on earth is a
solar-powered chemical reaction the
grass which or the phytoplankton in the
sea which is eaten by small organisms
which are eaten by larger predators and
then omnivores like us pretty much eat
everything
now in terms of climate change I talked
about in the book that has chapters in
the book about sailor agriculture and
saying well actually everybody could eat
lobster everybody could be Co based
steak but the point is it needs to be
meat without animals and we have the
technologies to do this and the carbon
footprint of cellular culture ninety
five percent and ninety five percent
less water a lot less labour and
obviously a lot less co2 and methane
emissions so that's a classic example of
a technology being able to help us the
question is can we roll it out quickly
enough will it be able to meet the
demands of the global south we're not
paid the market prices it's done so it's
technology there but we need to roll it
out much much quicker to address climate
change and sure we don't go beyond two
degrees C but there are many critics on
the left of the idea that fully
automated life Ecomuseum is a tube or
especially with the time frame which we
address the climate change how much of
it what I want socialism to be appealing
to everybody because like I say we had
leidos in the 1930s we had a council
estates of swing pools in the 1950s a
room today in the Golden Lane Estate a
room in a shared flat is 955 a month
this was a council flat back in the day
and now it's not in fact for a month so
yes I want to say to people your
assumptions that somehow we live in a
better place than we did 70 years ago
given phenological possibilities here
that's all time I was raised in a
council estate yeah no [ __ ] you were
raised on a council estate that council
estate now has a room for 950 per month
I wish I could live there for free
I can't so it's clearly an element I
want to market that's people but I'm
very very serious about radical social
democracy very generic forms of
socialism which we will know existent we
can comprehend them I want to say we're
the technological possibility is at hand
this can also be the bridge to something
else and I'm very serious about that
it's that an apt comparison to make
given that there are more people
demanding more resources now conversely
are we able to produce public subsidies
as we were able to do 67 years ago now
well you only need one pool in a in a
neighborhood I mean that's the point
it's about rights of access we're not
saying everybody has an infinity pool in
their back garden
it's about rights of access could you
access great education great health care
great recreational facilities for free
yes I mean that's why socialism is about
rights of access rather than rights of
ownership my favorite public space in
London rule festival south bank we built
that straight off the Second World War
we were bankrupt
we were destroyed London had been
decimated by the Luftwaffe and yet we
built I think the most stunning piece of
urban planning in London element Trump's
since so again I think there's an
ideological play in there that says we
can't do that if we create the South
Bank in the Royal Festival Hall in the
immediate aftermath in the second world
war the Festival of Britain I'm pretty
sure we could create public spaces are
that across the country Philly
automated luxury communism sounds like
quite my dear life society its that
achievable through social democracy I've
got expanded understanding a revolution
there are clearly some successful
examples of a revolution where people
got rid of millio that was running
society getting me speaking with it the
French Revolution was a success after
what happens the fuel aristocracy don't
just take working people for granted I
think most people probably think the
American Revolution was a good thing
certainly the United States they do
seems the founding fathers in the
Constitution had all kinds of appalling
things like slavery and so on wasn't
perfect but it began a journey to see
what became a liberal democratic state
that we know today 2019 but there are
also other kinds of revolution so you
can have a political or illegal
revolution you can also have a
revolution in the means of production
what Marx would call a new mode of
production it's the means of production
revolutionized and the capitalism from
feudalism to capitalism there's a
revolution according to Marx similarly
he would say there's a revolution
between capitalism communism not just
the level of people overthrowing regimes
but within the technological process
itself and so I would say understanding
or relating to nature in new ways is a
revolutionary act I would say new forms
of radical social relations gender
rights ending violence systemic violence
against women it's a revolutionary act
and what I want to say is that the
history of the 20th century is a history
where people within the left primarily
but not just the left privileged a
certain field of strugglers the place by
which you change society so an
anarchists would say we focus on social
relations a Marxist Leninist would say
we focus in the production process a
deep-green says we focus on relations
for nature a teleological termina says
we focus on technology you can ignore
everything else and what I would say as
a Marxist actually each of these spheres
matters and if you want to transform
society you need to understand each can
transform all of these things because
the great example is the Russian
Revolution 1917 they seized power what's
the first thing that they do Lenin and
Trotsky in the Bolshevik Party they look
at Frederick Taylor in America and they
say we want to apply the exact same
principles of advanced catalyst
production the Soviet Union so because
they didn't have a revolutionary
understanding of the production process
and of Technology so I would argue we
need a more her lips they can expand an
understanding revolution
democratic socialism is that socialism
horizontal forming up that's a really
great question
and I'm not so sure there's where I do
think they have a very strong democratic
socialist policy which one can talk
about is worker ownership funds being
advocates by John McDonnell and the key
reason why I think that's Democratic
socialists because he's not saying we
want the market to expand to pay for
provisions elsewhere kind of
distributists understanding of market
capitalism funding things we like he's
saying we want to change the
relationship of workers means production
so if you work for a footsie 250 company
you're gonna get 20% of the equity in
the business or you're gonna get a
certain dividend every year as a
shareholder so having that relationship
to a company not just as the employee
but also as the owner I think is
definitely Democratic Socialist know
shadow it out is the NHS a democratic
socialist project and the jury's out but
I think things about worker ownership
cooperative ownership and socializing
finance which makes that possible I
would absolutely call that Democratic
Socialist and I talk to economists in
this city and they say look we can
handle top rates of tax going up or down
we can handle corporation tax that
happens that politics one country does
it the other adapts that's fine well we
can't handle is infringement of private
property rights which is what worker
ownership funds are and so I think some
of these policies yeah there could be an
example of rescuing capitalism but
others such as socializing finance
worker and crops fee on businesses being
privileged
absolutely not that is very much at odds
with the interest of the ruling class do
we need a populist
beautiful left front internationally and
natural
sorry no robber SAS is good question
it's an important question because
obviously in Britain we have the issue
breaks it and in resisting the rise the
far right of course you should have
coalition's with centrists and I was
talking with Vince Cable earlier today
we agree about many things electoral
reform electing the House of Lords
radical federalism he probably wants to
hire minimum wage he probably wants more
regulation on banks but here's the thing
he's a social liberal I'm a social
liberal right I want LGBT rights women's
rights on a good migration policy etc
but he can't the [ __ ] defend his
economic orthodoxy and expect that
attitude of social liberalism
to persist because what's happening with
the economic liberalism he would defend
is this gradually eroding consent in our
system and that's not going to stop so
unless we offer significant powerful
alternatives and running our economy the
consent for the social liberalism will
continue to road as well so I think
that's a that's a question that liberals
have to ask themselves they won't defend
social liberal societies at the same
time you can't morally defend is making
that increasingly hard bread is one
manifestation of it so it's Donald Trump
the United States right Donald Trump
doesn't just win off the blue collar
vote but Rust Belt states which are
historically Democrat are the reason why
he's in the white house so if you won't
defend social liberal values I think you
also have to understand that we have to
fix the economy and that we can't just
turn back the clock to pre 2008 that's
not gonna happen
does socialism have to come through the
state I use think of it as a binary and
then about 2040 now it's Denmark and I
was hanging out in Copenhagen and squats
and that's you know cops their own
housing and so on
and what I was struck by was that all
these people could engage in all this
production outside of capitalism
side of the market but they can only do
it because of the strength of Danish
social democracy right you're working a
35-hour week you've got your housing
sorted you have a high minimum wage that
creates a certain surplus of resources
time cognitive capacity to do all these
other things outside the wage relation
so I think necessarily that kind of
politics is pretty predicated upon the
successful social democracy of the 20th
century
if it's one of the other possibly but
the reality is we live in a in a global
system determined by nation states as
the Paris Commune found out to his
detriment snowing a communist
self-governing commune in that context
is very very difficult so I think there
will always have to be a measure of but
at least the rest of our lives
of the nation stay enabling new forms of
socialism so this is where I would agree
with it is that public ownership since
the 1920s has been about state ownership
nationalization we need to increasingly
think about public ownership yes
sometimes nationalization right
I love the NHS but if you all think
about work around and cooperatively
owned businesses or resources housing
and that I think is the big challenge
for Corbin ISM there's obviously a lot
of it comes out of nationalization
top-down state socialism
you know everything and so I think it's
a think it's shifting both left and
right I think the sense was being
vacated at a very rapid pace now people
would say the Lib Dems are polling great
the fact that the entirety of political
centrism in this country is now
basically determined by the Baron breaks
it shows you how desiccated it is on
every other policy question which is a
problem so in the short term they might
win 30 40 seats the next election but in
terms of their vision about how you run
the economy with climate change with
them a traffic aging with their post
2008 context they have already got the
answers I don't like to say that because
like I say as a socialist your best bet
is having a broad coalition to win and
so what we're seeing instead is this
polarization some people go left
some people go right similar to what
happened in the 1930s and like I say the
Overton Window is moving and people are
more open to new ideas but only as an
outgrowth of an absence of confidence
and
as usual and look that's great for
navara that's great on the left that's
great for people coming to this festival
and talking about new ideas but it can
also have very detrimental impacts as
well and so that's why we have to
navigate that a lot we've been talking
about shifty Overton Window for years on
the left now it's happening but if we
don't seize the opportunity the right
will
are we able to shift the Overton Window
in the public sphere I think you have to
distinguish between debate democracy and
sectarianism and a lot of stuff that
happens on the left is just democratic
right and it's portrayed as their left
meeting itself but because of that
counter-revolution of Thatcherism
neoliberalism we don't know what
democracy even looks like you don't know
what it looks like
Labor's breaks in position you could say
I actually things been all over the
place but the the reality is the
position has been over time decided by
trade union leaders elected leader of a
party delegates from across the country
and ordinary parts of members and MPs
now it's not perfect but it's a lot
closer to democracy than how policy was
done under Tony Blair so yes it looks
dirty yes it doesn't look all clean and
smooth and we've got all the talking
points which plays so well on the ten
o'clock news but I want politics to look
like that
on the other hand there is some stuff
which isn't that right I'm not gonna be
about the bush but I do think that we're
the left coin caught eats itself
actually is an outgrowth of that
Democratic attitude and I think we've
not had radical democracy at the level
of a mass party it was so long the
people sometimes don't practice it
properly and you see this around a bunch
debates no bar to take anti-semitism
Jeremy Corbyn when he talks about the
mural I said yeah it's an anti-semitic
mural right yeah it's not the other
world apologize you know let's explain
what happened and let's move on well
awesome sack no no it's not I semantics
don't talk about that just deny it and I
think there's an absence of confidence
as to why there happens on the left and
so everything is felt as an attack by
establishment media establishment
interests often that's the case but we
don't have a confidence in ourselves
because we've only known defeat for 30
40 years so I think it's a little bit
more
and I hopefully I'm a bit more confident
we'll we will focus more on the
democracy than their eating ourselves up
but I think the two are related
are you worried about the structures of
mainstream media absolutely I mean let's
know I'm that's not a moral criticism of
journalists if you have a Twitter
account and you're rude to people you're
called a troll if you own a newspaper in
your roots people you're called a
newspaper owner and so people at Rupert
Murdoch who don't live here or the
Barclays brothers who live in Sark Lord
Rothermere with the Daily Mail mail
online these people are incredible
resources to influence public opinion
the left doesn't have that because
historically socialism labor based
movements haven't had the kinds of
resources that the right has the right
spends immense amounts of money for
people to think what they think I've
given examples on the climate strike
yesterday there was a lady she got up
and she said all these young people know
so much about climate change I feel
terrible between 2005 and 2015 in the
United States a hundred million dollars
was spent to resource climate denying
climate change denying
politicians institutions think tanks a
lot of money is spent for people to be
ignorant about this stuff and so I think
invariably yes mainstream media is
always going to help the right let me
say the far right but the
ultra-nationalist right the maid service
dry which complete into the far right on
the other hand we have to be and this is
the this is the terminal question for
the left we have the people we have the
numbers the question is one of
organization which also pertains to
media and I hope the more immediate
[Music]
solution
drink little discourse for the first
time particular line their first
interaction with that gives you identity
politics and that is a very polarizing
thing online is it evening in trance of
the left and right flesh Nets economic
discourse to also pair that with
identity politics and I see it again I
see the two mutually constitutive you
can't understand race without
understanding the economic basis of
colonialism you can't understand the
role of women in society I think as a
man without materialist feminist Marxism
right so I think that the two are are
deeply integrated I not give you an
example I was in Waterloo the other day
and I got the escalators and there's
just black a black guy first of course
you're not the Lion King then I go to
the toilet above every urinal is a
picture of a four year old emaciated
young girl black and people say we're
all the same no every single image I'm
being subjected to show me that black
people are very very different to how
we're yeah how we are in the West right
why is that it's because of how
capitalism develops over the last 500
years and so if somebody is a person of
color and they're angry how the police
relate to them behave to them absolutely
I'm not going to deny that fact and it's
a big you know from it's just a civil
you don't need to be a socialist to
address that you can be a liberal and
say no a quality end of the law what I
would say is there's a deeper context as
to why that is happening there's a
historical set of reasons as to why
that's happening and so I don't think
you can understand one without the other
however I want to dismiss identity
politics and say you don't you don't get
the whole thing I would say that the
economic kind of analysis enriches your
understanding of identity actually
particularly in Britain because we're a
post imperial power we need to be very
very clear about our role within
creating a world which is what we did
after 1700s a world of capitalism but
also a world of whiteness and the
creation of whiteness is a social
category it's a socially constructed
category yes clearly people have white
skin so if you like different colored
skins but that delineation of white
people from other people is a social
construct so I'll give an example if you
meet a Muslim convert
told me Robinson came out of prison the
other day had a big beard had hair we
were joking you look a Muslim convert he
actually reminded me of a Chechen that
fall for Isis in Iraq and the point is
how you racialized just threw away you
dress or your name or your facial hair
so my name might add my mother's
husband's name
it wasn't my dad Aaron Peters I was
clean-shaven I went to a grammar school
so I was racialized it's kind of like
European II Middle East he may be right
but if my name was tariq ramadhan and I
grow a beard I wearing it's a cure on my
head
I'm racialized as a Muslim so we need to
understand racialization the
construction of race and Britain played
a really important role in that that
shift alongside campus and that
construction and race because it done as
a deliberate authorization to obfuscates
direction away from yeah well my
colleague in tomorrow media shock will
give you a far more erudite asks and I
could offer but if you look at for
instance the Confederacy you know the
southern states the United States yet
working-class whites and the Confederacy
however they consented to a system where
they were subordinate to other white
people because they were above
working-class or indentured slave blacks
and so clearly in society that
distinction between the poorest poorer
of white communities and that being
reproduced by the interest because at
least it gives them succor to know
whether or not these people you see in
this country in the 19th century with
the Irish the poorest core of English
working class poor hated the Irish and
that suits Italy interests
extraordinarily well helps undermine
charters them hopes undermine
republicanism helps undermine labor made
socialism so couldn't agree more
although it's not that new you know I
think this is just integral to systems
of domination really since since the
18th century so how do we great done
that on the rise in our society Wow I
mean I would I would start with the
presumption we're all racist and it's a
perfectly healthy place to start we're
all racists and then I think we have to
constantly interrogate our relations to
women to trans people to people of color
nobody eliminates these things and this
is what I think our Marxist this is
disagrees the liberal right you can't
just step out of ideology right with
2,000 years old as a species you know
your ancestors God let's think of a
hundred thousand years ago their genome
is imprinted on you the social behaviors
which we've accumulated at the same time
yes that's not imprinted in your DNA
it's imprinted very much in our social
processes Goudy you can just step
outside of ideology step outside of
history you can't and so I think one of
the real the valuable things of marx in
the second half of 20th century is
understanding the oppression and
exploitation aren't the same thing
it took marks the teach us about
exploitation and the capitalism but it
took the scholars Frantz Fanon Michel
Foucault still refer to reach you it
took them to understand that oppression
is something a little bit different
sometimes almost always however this is
where I think Marx is very powerful they
overlap very very often oppressions
overlap Maitre matrices of exploitation
[Music]
within reason
I think it's more important to give them
resources you know you'll often go to an
event if you say oh let's ever let's
have a person of color speak woman of
color speaking of trans let's think the
platform is no good if they haven't got
the resources if they haven't had the
training if you have a white kid 25
years had the best education money can
buy and then you got a black kid turn
out they're not starting at the same
place so it's not about well we'll give
them a quality in the labor market will
give the same platform for them to speak
their mind they haven't had access to
the same set of resources so you need to
give them a platform we also need to
build a society where resources like
housing education health care transport
information wykel universal basic
services are available tool because I
believe in the liberal lens right I
believe that each person is uniquely
determined to define their own life but
that means nothing unless you have the
resources to do it
you're not self altering your life if
you haven't got a roof over your head or
if you haven't got education or if
you're sick so the platform's matter but
so do the resource and how we build
society more generally so beyond just
balancing to pay reparations so in the
global North in Britain I would see
constructing a socialist society where
housing education health care
reparations if it's freely available to
everyone regardless of race or class I
view that as a kind of reparations in
terms of north/south relationship
obviously a bit different I would say
the global North should pay for global
South the transition away from fossil
fuels I talked about that in the book
you do that through some of the
mechanisms I talked about with
socializing finance national best banks
and that was a few things it helps us
meet our targets quick cleaner but it
also as you've highlighted helps us to
begin to address the historical
inequality is built on racism and campus
addressing the crisis again it seems do
you think that's a direct way of working
well some of the things I do space is
actually quite profitable if you want to
send satellites into space you know we
use GPS coordinates we know the fact we
even know about climate change at all is
entirely contingent on satellites right
but there are some kind of gratuitous
examples Elon Musk sending a Tesla into
space clearly that's not helping anybody
and so they're doing this one addressing
the climate crisis and what's really
tragic and actually this is one of the
most the single for which I think is
most tragic Thor in the history of
humanity is that 85% of all co2
emissions have been created since the
Second World War
40% of co2 emissions have been created
since Taylor Swift was born 25 percent
of co2 emissions his hearts believed had
been created since the iPhone was
released in the last three years China
has used more concrete than America did
in the whole 20th century right so we're
doing far more more to destroy the
planet fully aware of the consequences
than we ever did in ignorance and that
is terrifying now how has that happened
partly you could say Katz's but I also
think since 1989 the end of history
the end of an alternative is that we and
again as a historical tragedy just at
the precise moment we could have shifted
our economies away from fossil fuels you
have the end of history you have
supremacy of market capitalism there is
no alternative and so I sometimes wonder
you know the USSR was actually
incredibly polluting and ecologically
destructive but if there was an
alternative society that was addressing
certain problems in certain ways maybe
we would have changed course - because
you need to understand the 20th century
history of social democracy through the
prism of there was this big old Turner -
called the Soviet Union you might not
like it but there were left-wing
movements in Britain in Germany and
France and Italy and they had this
alternate society turns I didn't work
but I do question the inability of an
alternative saw that not redoing much
about climate change and also this
attitude of there are no solutions
unless we all let's go that all at the
same time and what I think that is
actually as a license to not do anything
I think that really serves elite
interests and so I think in Britain boom
say well we're only responsible for 1%
of co2 emissions globally so what that's
what we're that's what we're responsible
for end of story and I think that
attitude of offering a pro stock to the
world yes let's be the first country to
decarbonize for 2030 you know we can't
keep on waiting for multilateral
agreements it's not it's not working
yeah let's say we do China still you
that's true Bruce you have to remember
China is 20% of the global economy or to
play nice in the global population so
per head it's still not as bad at the
United States
it's just 1.3 billion people that said
China's done a lot more actually in
recent years to address this stuff from
the US China people don't know this
China since I think 2008 has rewarded a
surface area the size of Ireland right I
mean of course it's very easier no
planning permission but that's the kind
of thing we need to be doing in this
country you say look we're gonna we're
gonna rewire the forest the size of the
new forest in five to ten years that
kind of thing is far easier for Chinese
- because of their political system at
the same time their world leaders in in
renewable energy the fact that we don't
and it's one of the argument against the
EU membership I'm not making the
argument that somebody could is that we
buy PV PV cells photovoltaic cells from
other European countries because they're
import tariffs placed on Chinese ones
and actually if they weren't there we
could buy those solar cells for cheaper
and we could roll out on your Balaji far
more quickly in this country it's a
really powerful argument right so listen
up we have to remember the EU because
then we can all coordinate and
decarbonize rapidly well it's a bit more
complicated so yeah China has to
decarbonize but to be honest given their
level of development it's done a very
poor country in many parts of it they
have shown I think really significant
leadership on on solo war so the United
States on the Dora Trump there's an
argument that we will not be able to
reduce output sustained like this planet
given up in this planner if populations
aren't controlled and the
counter-argument is that that is what is
the class try it's the whole debate
around the environment so take emissions
you know oh well we don't any car buys
you don't to punish the working family
that has their annual holiday to Spain
we have frequent flyer points in this
country right we're literally
incentivizing people to fly as much as
possible we have private jets scrap them
scrap business class because actually if
we're gonna fly at all we have to all
fly like you fly right now and Ryanair
eight I hate to break it to be watching
that because there's really no other
alternative but it really won't be a
fossil fuel vehicle you know hopefully
in 40 50 years to five so class strikes
it I think throughout and terms the
global kind of argument about you know
population limits this is a Matthews you
know it's not a new argument about we
have too many people and I I don't
really accept some of his premises so
1800 we were population about which is
where Malthus was rising we have
population about a billion people right
so clear he was wrong because we now
have 7.5 billion people and the average
person is eating more calories and they
were in mouth this time that said
there's clearly a hard limit it's a
planet right you know we don't have
infinite resource on this planet could
we sustain a population of 10 billion
yeah for 1112 billion the highest of
high estimates by the end of this
century don't reach 12 billion a which
point countries the global South have
birth replacement rates full like we've
had in Europe and North America South
America and the population goes down so
can we sustain a global action of 11
billion yeah we can and that's going to
be the high point and so the our mission
shouldn't be oh you know we can't these
people can't afford to do the things we
do it's gonna require a global effort
decarbonize across the planet but also
yeah yeah we need to talk about birth
replacement rates which actually
people have highest answer living in
place on sub-saharan Africa yeah you
want a birthplace of native-like 2.5 it
tends to correlate with women's suffrage
it tends to correlate with more people
in the labor market it tends to
correlate with higher rates of literacy
both men and women so I don't buy the
argument about the David Attenborough
argument right we just need to have less
people know because the planet today
could sustain about 2.5 billion people
if we all ate a diet equivalence that
the average American and if we all let
it die equivalent to the average person
in South Asia it can sustain about 10
billion without any technological
innovations and right now we're at about
seven point five seven point six billion
so I think that's an argument really
serves the interest it serves the global
north and I think it's kind of racist
argument fundamentally but also from a
science perspective which matters most
not true so returning to democracy to
action no wait firstly I'm not an
advocate of personal change an advocate
of mass political change however there
are some personal things you could do
the first is stop eating me absolutely
right and why whether it's water
shortages whether its land use for the
Amazon this is because of meat
consumption co2 emissions and methane
coming from cattle huge also I think
giving up meat forsaking me changes your
relationship to nature you know it's not
you might call it ethical consumption I
think making that choice they no longer
eat fellow animals is actually a really
profound shift in how you relate to
everything so that's one thing another
thing is to fly less try not to fly at
all obviously that's easy for some
people others if you work in different
countries your relatives I get that
domestic flights internal flights there
is absolutely no excuse whatsoever the
five from Glasgow to London
none at all that's the personal stuff
then the political stuff is join a trade
union whatever you do you've got camera
operators here I have there maybe
they're paid nuj rates I don't know join
me on UJ join your night join unison
join the GMB and by the way they're
pollen successional somethings are
terrible but they're only gonna change
by people joining them so that's one
thing
and we're not going to transform society
in green society by all you know I know
some people have given up overing I saw
a lady of the climbing stroke she said
this skirt is fifty years old
we're all going to do that we need to
transform society through mass
production of how we all relate to
society so join a trade union I would
say join a political party a progressive
political party I personally I remember
the Labour Party I'm not like tell other
people they should do but evangelize for
this city on climate change but that's
we're talking about evangelize those
policies my view is right now three
parties in the UK Serious Man climate
change labor greens SNP by the way
Scotland by next year all its
electricity from renewables so people in
tree talk about it that's real
leadership that's my view but even if
you're already in the Liberal Democrats
even through auditing the Tory Party
which are increasingly I hope people on
if you're in these parties you need to
really say look we need a systems change
around energy otherwise we're gonna have
a world of three four degrees warming
and whatever you care about like I said
in the talk whether its gender violence
whether it's crime whether it's
education attainment whether it's cheer
politics climate change is going to
determine all of this and so I would say
that act of associative democracy but
being involved in things talking to
people this kind of stuff right
political institutions when you're doing
that constantly is the most so yeah oh
[Music]
my god yes there's a there's a
fetishization of young people right and
LOL and put it really well that talk
there this stage army for all people to
basically you know young people wanted
to stop for exit and that's the stage
army for all the people that young
people generally I'll remain fine but
actually look at protests around breaks
it and then look at the climate strike
which had bigger numbers you know and
young people aren't stupid they know
that this issue if you're fifteen
sixteen you're gonna hopefully live a
long life to 89 see this is gonna shake
your entire life if I have one our kids
he'll check their entire life
and so I think young people the shocking
thing is about this intuitively seem to
have a structure analysis of what's
going on so the thing about oh I'm only
hoovering two days a week please Hoover
as much as you can that will not stop
climate change by giving up hoovering
all the people say that oh this skirt is
fifty years old you know young people
say no we need to transform society we
need to transform how we relate to each
other we need to transform what we eat
we need to transform what the world of
work they have structural answers now
where's that coming from I don't know
but I'm very glad it's happening for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you